[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] em indeed
friday
let's make joe mansion
irrelevant again
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i don't know any other way to put it
here's the thing joe manchin gives us
the majority
in the senate
so that way
some [ __ ] can get done but obviously joe
manchin
does not want to be a part of the
pro-democracy democratic
small d small l liberal
that coalition it is very obvious um he
is only holding his place
so that way the fascists can't take over
the country so we as a people and as a
democracy need to make mansion
irrelevant again that's right i don't
know if that's a national slogan that
can be taken seriously or not but i
think with fetterman with tim ryan with
warnock and some of the other candidates
that we have out there for these senate
races we definitely can make joe manchin
irrelevant again [ __ ] that guy one guy
should not be dictating what we can and
cannot do in this country
this is [ __ ] ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous
he's not even using the filibuster at
this point it's the mansion buster jesus
christ
just walk out and go ah [ __ ] the climate
oh you like clean air
[ __ ] you oh oh you want you want to
raise taxes
to make sure it's fair and balanced in
this country on rich people [ __ ] you
these people give me money
what are you what are you crazy you
think i'm gonna raise taxes on my donors
you think i'm gonna put
put regulations on my donors here
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] so let's make him irrelevant
we can't vote him out that's not a thing
he's not up for a re-election so he
can't vote him out
so but what you can do what you can do
is engage in your ballot have strategic
outrage stay [ __ ] pissed
about joe manchin and get out there and
[ __ ] work for these senate races and
make mansion irrelevant again [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him that's what he's that's what
he's doing anyways
is he's using the power that he has
to just give the middle finger to
anything that he wants to the middle
finger that he wants to give to anything
that democrats do
he has to get trump votes in west
virginia folks
he relies on it
so he has to hate him some democrats and
hate him some some trump
art excuse me love him some trump
everyone's gonna hate trump here soon
that [ __ ] jesus christ do you
see this
i cannot believe this
ivana trump his first wife dies from
falling down the stairs apparently
there's an investigation i don't know
what you could say about that but
the deposition of donald trump now maybe
the kids i understand but the new york
ag has delayed the the deposition of
donald trump and new york
against the civil trial against trump
organization the money money laundering
machine that is the trump org
donald trump his his his deposition has
been delayed because he's sad get the
[ __ ] out of here that guy doesn't give a
[ __ ] about anyone but himself
and this weekend he's still going to go
to his [ __ ] clan rally
and rile up all the ninja poop nazis at
his [ __ ] nazi rally give me a [ __ ]
break
i think the new york the new york
attorney general tess james should
reconsider immediately
as soon as possible get that fat [ __ ]
under oath and question him [ __ ] [ __ ]
him he didn't give a [ __ ] about his wife
jesus christ she even used the word rape
he raped her
[ __ ] out of here he's sad and [ __ ] so
they're gonna delay it i mean the kids
maybe i understand i don't know
you know i i think i think we've had
enough of this delaying [ __ ]
and it deserves some attention here
but this idea that somehow they're going
to delay his deposition
and he's still going to go act all happy
and and cheery at his nazi rally this
weekend get the [ __ ] out of here
get the actual [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
not i'm not convinced are you convinced
i'm not convinced that donald trump is
sad
and his first wife who he raped she said
it
not me
his past i doubt that he has any
feelings about it whatsoever at all
i mean jesus christ he was fundraising
off of it in a goddamn email
fundraising over death
whoosh
whoosh
let the conspiracy theories continue
there's all kinds of news this morning
you also have noticed that the secret
service were deleting text messages from
january 5th and the 6th
huh wonder what that could be about
couldn't couldn't be about couldn't be
about the coup
or the coup attempt or what the plan was
that day from the cheeto dust mobster
could it nah that couldn't be it at all
that couldn't be why they were deleting
text
get the [ __ ] out of here of course it is
of course it
is we're gonna have to have a come to
jesus moment with with our law
enforcement and our protective services
and even the military in this country
come to jesus
these people took an oath and they need
to uphold that oath and if there's any
just a [ __ ] hint just a whiff
yes the stench
that you have brick in your oath prison
for you [ __ ]
i'm not for locking people up but this
is enough of this [ __ ]
enough of this [ __ ]
they're trying they're trying to get
ultra maga
infiltrated into every single facet of
our lives
law enforcement congress
secret service military
it's [ __ ] everywhere [ __ ] out of here
with this trader ass [ __ ]
we're gonna watch some video here here's
the plan today we today's friday we got
bonehead bonehead of the week today
bonehead of the week it is friday we
will do bonehead of the week in the
second hour
it's where you vote
if you're a new listener out there
here's what bonehead of the week is
we put a poll out on twitter
you guys go vote for bonehead of the
week at tony michael's pod so go follow
us there on twitter at tonymichaelspod
or you can vote you can vote on the
youtube channel follow us here on
youtube subscribe to the tony michael's
podcast right here on youtube you can
vote here too
you vote for bone of the week and we
break down your vote every single friday
in the second hour of the show because
we air two hours on friday frankly every
single weekday monday through friday we
air for two hours on youtube twitter and
twitch and simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page
but on fridays it's special in the
second hour me and gabe my co-host and
executive producer
we break down
your vote for bonehead of the week so
make sure to go vote every thursday
or thursday night you know somewhere in
there friday morning for bone end of the
week
and we'll break it down for you but
today i have a special interview
i interviewed dakota von adams stuart
rhodes is a strange son i asked him
about jason
van tattenhove
and he breaks some news
um
he breaks some news about how close
stewart and jason tattenhove actually
were
like friendship wise
and maybe even physically wise i don't
know
i don't know exactly the
details but as you know
dakota is stuart stewart rhodes the
founder of the oath keepers a strange
son
and he has some insight into the
personal
uh dealings with not only stewart but
also jason
uh you're gonna get his take on what he
thought about his testimony which is the
reason why i wanted to have him on but
he also said some stuff about jason and
stuart that was
i i i hadn't uh i hadn't heard that
before out loud
so uh and and the committee did not ask
about these things
about his relationship that he may or
may not have had a certain type of one
with stuart other than just being the
oath keeper's propagandist
and a writer and a journalist apparently
um under a pseudonym as well after he
left under his real name
and there is a debate about when he left
and when he didn't and how long and
dakota kind of breaks that down a bit
it's it's even confusing to people who
were inside the inner circle
of what when jason actually left the
oath keepers it seems as if he left
mentally
but hadn't actually broke away from the
oath keepers for a bit
uh the other piece of uh information
inside the interview that you'll see
it's about 30 minutes long and we're
going to play it at the bottom of the
hour so here's what'll happen we'll go
to the bottom of the hour we'll play the
interview with dakota and then at the
top of the hour when we come back from
the break from the interview with dakota
we will go to bonehead of the week so
that is the plan for today on the show
the tony michaels podcast that's the
plan
but he also talks about um
in this piece that it is very unclear
when jason left the oath keepers but
also he talks about a custody hearing
you know that stewart uh and his wife
tasha were estranged
tasha's been trying to get a divorce
which is dakota's mother for a while now
and um jason actually
testified for stuart
in that custody battle so you'll hear
hear dakota talk about that so
jason is intertwined with
stuart rhodes and
dakota adams his estranged son natasha
adams they're
intertwined
with their personal lives as well so
dakota has some special insight into
jason but he also gives you
his take on what actually jason said to
the select committee and how the select
committee did questioning him and even a
little bit about uh ayers
the the uh
convicted
capital insurrectionist the january 6
insurrectionist that he was a cabinet
maker he lost his job his house i mean
he he he has since
uh renounced donald trump and realized
it was all [ __ ] and all lies
and he's trying to move on with his life
i guess
maybe i don't know but we'll well but
dakota talks about steven ayers in the
um i think his name steven um in the in
the uh mystery ears i know that is uh
that is it uh in the interview here so
at the bottom of the hour we will play
that interview
but i have some video i want to play for
you um gabe was going to join us let me
see if i can get him on the horn here he
wanted to watch some of this video with
you and um because it is
marjorie taylor green
uh and and someone we watched yesterday
and we watched yesterday this uh [ __ ]
tucker carlson wannabe
uh sexually harassing out in
in at the capitol steps sexually
harassing
uh uh aoc
where he was taking a video and he
posted it online
and
she reposted now in the video
aoc yeah she almost decides to uh
rip his little head off it seems and i'm
sure she would have if she could have or
got a hold of him um he seems like a
[ __ ] cuck a huge cuck
so but we're going to break down this
video
um of marjorie t he went on marjorie
taylor green's
little traitor podcast that she has
and he was talking i think that's what
he was talking about is the
the the uproar about him
openly sexually harassing
a congresswoman
he's like oh it's just a joke she's so
pretty blah blah blah no you were such a
harassing her you dumbass
that's what you were doing that's what
that's called you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
oh okay let's let's go to the
let's go to the tweets here i'm not
going to do the music we're just going
to go into it because we get about 15
minutes until we get to the bottom of
the hour for
actually you know what let's just start
the countdown just start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we have reached the part of the show
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and then trendy trends the [ __ ] list
roundup we got about 15 minutes to round
up the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends here now before we go to the
interview with dakota so let me let me
make this a little bigger here because i
want to go to uh i just want to get
right to right to the point here
uh we have a video uh well i want to
watch this one too god damn it there's
so much video we need to go to three
hours i keep telling gabe we got to go
to three hours man we just ain't got
enough time to do this [ __ ] we got
enough time to cover all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] we don't we don't have time to
show america all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
and why you have to go [ __ ] vote to
make mansion irrelevant again
that's what we have to do
i keep telling gabe this game i keep
telling you over and over and over again
we need three hours there's just too
many [ __ ] out there there's just too
many [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah there are too
many they're just everywhere these
[ __ ] are everywhere so here here is
a king [ __ ] from um the other day um
we it was it was yesterday right this is
in recent memory no two days ago was it
two day jesus yeah yeah alex stein this
this [ __ ] just alex stein stein99
is what he says
is that so because that's his twitter
account i actually tagged this
[ __ ] i'm going to show you don't
worry i've got some stuff that i want to
tag him in later in the show oh
fantastic well hopefully we'll get to
him hey did you are you secretly are you
secretly holding something for bone end
of the week here because i don't know
okay i got you
see here's what happens folks most the
time gabe kind of decides the bonehead
of the week i mean it's kind of
collaboration but most time i give him
who who because he's doing all the art
and all that kind of stuff so all the
art you see for bonehead of the week is
definitely not me um
it's definitely not me it's totally it
is totally gabe um but but this [ __ ] box
here
he's been featured a couple times on
this show because he is an [ __ ] uh
one of the times was we discussed the
other day when he went after
um he called him eyepatch mccain which i
actually don't think is a bad nickname
yeah it's not a bad nickname uh and he
also which is dan crenshaw and he went
after ted cruz too which hey if anyone's
willing to go after ted cruz hey fine
you know what am i gonna say about it
but he's still an [ __ ] right yeah
yeah because he didn't he didn't talk
about how ted cruz had a nice ass he was
talking about how ted cruz is he didn't
talk about how nice of a beard ted cruz
right exactly
exactly exactly that's not what he said
but he did he did that to um aoc he was
sexually harassing her and and open in
the open
right yeah it's all a dude it was just a
joke man
stop being so sensitive tony right
yep
well i'm not sensitive here's the thing
is
aoc looked like she was gonna kick his
[ __ ] ass oh yeah dude she was like
i'm about to throw hands 100
i mean and then she realized you know
what this guy's got a camera and i
totally would murder this son of a [ __ ]
like i would imagine like the [ __ ]
capital police show up and she's
standing on the capitol steps with his
head in her hand and the body laying on
like like a kathy griffin moment right
kind of [ __ ] right right right this
little punk ass [ __ ] wouldn't last two
[ __ ] seconds with aoc and she's
throwing hands no [ __ ] way this
[ __ ] rube i'm surprised he's not
wearing a bow tie why doesn't he wear
bow ties i mean well here like i said
i've got more to reveal because i did a
little great digging oh okay good good
we'll we'll get to that let's play this
because he he showed up on a traitor uh
tv podcast whatever the hell this thing
here's the other set by the way this is
better better camera better lighting
better everything this is she does this
has to be in dc this has to be in dc
probably
so what am i using taxpayer money for to
build my studio the other one i have no
idea maybe because it's the same one
though the other one it's not like it's
a different hotel room each time right
right no it's the same i feel like it's
gotta be
in
in georgia maybe like i don't know where
else it would be i mean like i'm
surprised like if you're gonna have a
show why would you do it in a crappy
[ __ ] blank wall hotel room i don't
know right or maybe that's in dc and
this is in georgia i don't know and i
i've i've knocked her for her for her
microphone um stuff
uh you know how she does a microphone
now these are different microphones here
than what she has in the hotel room
whatever the hell that is in the hotel
room she actually has a condenser
microphone these are dynamic mics so a
condenser microphone just to explain
it's kind of what i have you know you
can talk and when you're loud like i am
it just you know the microphone picks up
the whole sound right but these are
dynamic mic which means you have to talk
directly into them yeah directly into
them she doesn't get it in these clips
because she she keeps turning her head
and you can't understand what she's
saying because she talks way over there
it really she's a dumb [ __ ] but let's
watch
and you know the people obviously are
watching this that are they're to be mad
that we're getting sarcastic but there's
the people that no we're not mad because
you're sarcastic that's not that's not
what it is that's not what it i mean not
not even i'm [ __ ] funny bro it was
sarcasm i'm not i'm really not even mad
at these [ __ ]
i'm not even really mad at him to be
quite honest with you i mean there's a
lot of [ __ ] to be mad about right to be
mad about the the one in the red there's
a lot of [ __ ] to be mad about she's a
[ __ ] congress person for crying out
loud yeah an irrelevant one at that
can't even get on a [ __ ] committee
but this guy you're [ __ ] cuck you're
a [ __ ] joke you little [ __ ] running
around yelling and screaming and and
sexually harassing congresswoman get out
of here yeah thinking that shit's funny
you're not [ __ ] funny you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] let's listen i go
after you like patriot takes and all
these people and they try to get after
us they don't wait wait what who'd he
say yeah he dropped he dropped a name
there he dropped the name he dropped
patriotics what's funny about this is
marjorie taylor green he's been after
patriot takes for i don't know um
weeks now right because they kind of
we're having a tiff because
dropped all the text messages right well
because patriot takes just
takes what she says and posts it on
right on twitter yeah like he doesn't i
mean it's edited like it's clipped the
front and the back but i mean it's it's
what she says if anyone
has any sort of doubt as to the clips
that patriot takes has put out there on
twitter you could easily just go to
margie taylor green's facebook page and
she's got the videos right there right
unedited the whole breakthrough yeah not
even the clips just the whole [ __ ]
thing you can watch all this trash why
are you guys using my own words against
me
right i said that but i said that hoping
that no one else would do that like
yeah she's a [ __ ] idiot don't play
the victim you said it own up to it just
like you were like we warned you guys
about january 6 we were going to storm
the capital it was your fault you guys
didn't do anything about it it's like
we're gonna try and victim blame all
right i wonder if this studio that she's
in if this is where ted cruz shoots his
little traitor tv thing oh and then matt
gatz right it's like a sedition studio
yeah yes edition sedition studio yeah
it's brought to you by sedition studios
yeah i don't know maybe that might be a
thing all right let's see i have a sense
of humor you have a sense of humor like
we can actually be well you know that's
the thing is we can actually be affable
and laugh when we realize that the world
is you know we're meant to have fun
we're not meant to constantly be scared
and fighting each other so we don't go
after these problems but these are the
people that i i gotta tell you these
[ __ ] they've been watching our show i'm
gonna show you proof here in a bit
they've been watching our show i'm going
to show you proof well let's finish
listening we're trying to create the
division the people that are going after
us for making jokes for bringing all of
this
crazy stuff to the life that they're
trying to hide of course of course
i'm almost i i am almost 100 positive
when he said affable she was like
what
it's like
does anyone have a dictionary handy
that's like the other day when uh when
she she had matt gates on and they were
talking and then she was like
she was like off like looking and like
thinking to herself like
what does that word mean
and then and then and then she's just
like she's taking
she's taking the cue off the coat like
the guest and they're like they're
laughing they're smiling okay
and so then her cue is like this she
goes
apple ball
what is what whatever that means yeah so
i want to point out in this one how
these [ __ ] i think i think we
need to i we may
need to send a cease and desist here to
these people taking our our what
the bits that that we do here um
let's listen to this one this is where
she can't figure out how the microphone
works but they're talking about some
they're they're trying to be funny again
let's listen i'm trying to brag i got a
couple i got a couple clicks on the
internet and well you know it's easy
because my biology obviously you're
saying things hold on you're saying
things that no one agrees with she's
like shut up you
shut up you
shut up you
she can't run the [ __ ] microphone
so she she tells him to shut up and then
she's telling him something but listen
to what he says after she tries to make
her dumbass point
so i mean why would anybody follow you
listen to you only because my my father
he used the white power hour tucker
carlson helped me out so if it wasn't
what was that
you might need to do a what was that on
this listen yeah listen to you only
because my my father he helps the white
power hour tucker cross and help me out
so
okay so i just want to i just want to
say i've been calling them traitor tv
for [ __ ] a year now traitor tv
network their [ __ ] traders seditious
studios whatever you want to call it
here and and and and really we did a
a a bit
back in november during thanksgiving
and the bit was called
uh
white privilege tonight with carl
tuckerson this [ __ ] is stealing
our [ __ ] man i know i think he's i think
he's gone to our youtube channel and
he's really skimming through all the
videos over there well we also will we
know that he knows about our stuff from
yeah yeah we know he we know he knows we
know he knows who we are
we we we you know i it's you know you
might say this joke but we legitimately
know he knows who we are for another
reason it's on video that he knows who
we are yeah
it's on the internet that he knows who
we are let's let's watch it wasn't for
him in the white power hour then i would
nobody would know who i am so the white
power thank you thank you mike yeah
network they're they're like let's laugh
about this but really it's what we're
training is this is the truth we
actually
do like white power hour we would make
it white lifetime if we could um
it's really it's really funny because
here here is the tweet now i'm not going
to play the video yeah
i'm going to retweet it here so youtube
is going to ding you for something we
already own
this is this is rn and it's really news
now it's really it really is news game
yeah it's a it's a legitimate uh news
channel i'm sure if seth wants to you
know dive in and check it out he can
figure out yeah it's really really new
it's re it even says it's really news
yeah um but this is a this is a bit that
we did
and it was uh it was about crt because
at the time they were freaking out about
crt last thanksgiving it was called
woke's
giving we had our friend jojo from
jurors she came and played uh uh uh
becky sue which is hilarious because she
was a hilarious character and she came
and she helped us out with this with
this bit uh where she went on a show
called
white privilege tonight with carl
tuckerson so the other the other thing
about this bit is that in their
crt we joked about how it was critical
race training that's right and then i
think within two three weeks margie
taylor green camp she comes out in the
video and she goes with that critical
race
training
and it's like
what's going on here either we either we
predict the future on the show
or somebody is watching our stuff or
both i don't know i i can't figure it
out i can't figure it out but but i i
even i tagged him to make sure he knew
we knew he's out there and we because we
know he's watched our stuff we know he's
watched our stuff before so i tagged him
and and asked the question
should i send him a cease and desist for
trying to lift our [ __ ] material
that's all i was trying to say and
here's the video i'm not going to play
the audio because it's disgusting but
here's the video of him sexually
harassing
aoc on the again you know they try they
they try to
act like it's a joke right it's not like
oh they don't get the joke it's like
well if you're being misogynistic and
you're making fun of someone's
appearance you know whether you're
saying oh it's not making fun i'm
calling i'm talking about her booty i'm
talking about how beautiful is that
sweet sweet latina and it's like okay
one back the [ __ ] off
and two
the fact that you're trying to disguise
this as uh a joke but really it is
misogyny right like i i wouldn't be
surprised if this is how you handle your
relationships uh other women in your
life
uh just the general uh lack of respect
toward any human
right like this is the same
characteristics of people within the
republican party where it's like i joke
i'm sarcastic but really
i mean it you know well here's one more
person who's upset that people don't
like him how's that how's that app get
her doing i i just i just want to play
this before we go to the break and then
to the uh
uh the interview with dakota here now
you couldn't make it for the interview
gabe you you had a dentist appointment
or something i i had a dentist
appointment and you gave me [ __ ] you
gave me [ __ ]
for not so i'm gonna i i don't know if
it's true or not but uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna blame it that you had a different
rumor rumor has it i was at the dentist
when tony was was holding down the fort
for this involvement we're gonna show to
be 100 honest we actually tried to
record this with dakota a day before but
i actually had to go back to the dentist
and because they gave me some locals for
for the work that i had done that day he
was looking like
i look i look like i had a stroke
and and i
yeah we could have just like lip-synched
and i could have said the things that
you were speaking and then i would just
see my face well you know there is apps
that we could probably have made do like
a face app and yeah it could have been
ah i didn't even think about that god
damn it we missed an opportunity oh well
i have this interview but let's watch
but let's watch jason miller here
complain about how he doesn't get any
[ __ ] engagement on twitter because
he's he's a worthless piece of [ __ ] i
don't know fairly large number of uh
engagements uh with anything i post on
getter yes oh a fairly large number i
mean he gets dozens of people on on
getter the dozens of people that are
actually over there they actually talked
to him
very active very active community look
at those notifications tens
tens of likes yeah you know how long i
feel like
in order to get notifications up to 99
he had to leave this
untouched
untouched for at least two and a half
weeks right right and he's like no
got it okay close screenshots
nobody touched this nobody touched this
computer i need it for the interview
nobody [ __ ] touch it nobody touch it
what a dumbass let's listen to how he
complains about twitter
twitter i still have you know almost 400
000 followers there and now frequently
i'll have one retweet two retweets is it
nuts and
it's almost it's almost joe as if
someone said wait a minute this is the
ceo of a competitor platform let's make
sure nobody sees his stuff no that's not
what it is your tweets just they suck
man they [ __ ] suck and and
half his following is probably fake
anyways is that what you're doing let's
let's just check this out gabe's doing
an audit gabe's doing speaking of this i
because i'm going to go back to march or
taylor green for a second because i know
yesterday you called her and you left
her a voicemail did you ever hear back
from marjorie never never called me back
marge does not return phone calls son of
a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] well she will call you
right away to tell you how to commit
voter fraud allegedly right but she saw
you back answering me back on my phone
jason miller has
374 000 so
to say you're nearly at i feel like it's
it's like saying you get all it's like
saying you get a lot of engagement on
getter right yeah yeah
hold on we got 15 seconds before this uh
this little audit comes back to me but
yeah jason miller he's like oh no not to
brag it's like well if you why are you
even on the platform then if you don't
like twitter and you're complaining
about not getting the engagement you
want on twitter like you'll get a
retweet here and there then why are you
even complaining all right 96 000
followers 90 almost 97 96 903 fake
followers jason miller
um
is what he has of course 25.9
so my guess is is he probably bought
about a hundred grand
probably a hundred thousand a hundred
dollars i mean remember that you know
the other thing too is like twitter goes
through and they're they're pruning
followers and and people tweeting
or bots tweeting
before you even know that they're on the
platform too so they're like going
through it's you know the other ones
that make it through that seem somewhat
legit
but jason miller for again for someone
who's like i've got this app and i'm the
ceo of this app over here it's like all
right why are you complaining
about twitter
if you're trying to use
getter like this is a this is a a
marketing tactic that you use if you're
a smaller brand this is what he's doing
here if you're a smaller brand right you
would as a bigger brand you would never
go and attack someone who's smaller than
you because there's no need right you
have the market share you have the reach
yeah the the
the punching down as opposed to punching
up guys right right we we know all too
well people that have punched down
before there was even a guy last week
seth
uh who did that
what if you're a lawyer
but if you're like a bmw you would never
make an ad about like kia right like you
would never do that it doesn't make any
sense but if you're kia
you would make an ad comparing yourself
to say like we have now the luxury
quality that is a standard uh that
competes with bmw right
and that's what jason miller is doing
here he's doing this marketing tactic
which is to compare himself a smaller
not very successful in this in this
comparison uh social network to say that
he is
of equal stature
to
twitter
but he complains about how twitter
treats him because he's like oh if there
was a social network competitor ceo on
twitter why wouldn't we suppress it it's
like dude it's not that we're
suppressing on twitter or that twitter's
suppressing you it's that no one on
twitter [ __ ] cares right they don't
like you you suck and it sucks take your
balls
sucks it sucks to suck it's and that's
what it really is yes yes well everybody
stick around right after this
right after this you're gonna watch
dakota adams tell us what his thoughts
were because he knows gaby knows jason
tatino very personally and he knows some
stuff about jason that i didn't know
from the hearing and then the hearing
didn't cover
about how closely stuart rhodes and
jason detno might
have been to each other
i don't know let's stick around you will
find out in the interview watch the
entire interview with dakota von adams
right after these messages stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us we have a reoccurring guest
i'm super excited to ask him about his
response
to the
jason van tattenhove i believe is how
you say his name the former oath keeper
um i i view him kind of as a
propagandist i don't know if he said
exactly that um but i i do view him as
the oath keeper's propagandist he was
actually named propagandist and then he
kind of went under a different name
to continue that
i want to welcome dakota von adams
dakota welcome welcome welcome to the
podcast again uh last week we talked
about
some of the militia movement and how the
right wing
on the internet uses groups like 4chan
and stuff to
dilute the minds of some of these young
people but today we're here to talk
about
the response that you have from the
testimony of jason van tattenhove and
the january 6th select hearing
but i think it's kind of the same thing
isn't it where
jason kind of says hey these people are
being brainwashed kind of like what we
were talking last week is it it did i
get that sense right yes but especially
in a
in online messaging and in the priming
people
to commit violence
when the when the call up happens now
jace uh jason's position
i believe he does call himself a
propagandist in some prior interviews
and that's entirely fair as a label and
uh
jason
was
basically single-handedly responsible
for
the most successful of the oath keepers
digital
imprint and their digit and their
internet impact after the era of
blogspot
where they were highly successful all
more recent oath keepers success
in online messaging
uh jason had a hand in that through when
he separated with oath keepers and it's
funny because
he would have at the time he got
involved with oath keepers and became
their media coordinator was basically
the exact moment that oh hebrews began
to take that hard turn
into being a militia
instead of the gradual transformation
that it had been leading up to bundy
ranch
now
your family has a lot of history with
jason just because uh stuart rhodes the
founder of the oath keepers your
estranged uh father um lived with jason
but also
had a very
kind of weird relationship but he had
weird relationships
throughout his adult life stoop being
steward
he would sleep on people's couches he
would kind of hermit with people in
their houses uh jason didn't touch too
much on that um but tell me a little bit
about that relationship that your family
kind of has with jason and how you know
jason and if you know him or have talked
to him tell us about what you know about
jason yep so jason uh after beginning to
work for oath keepers following those
standoffs that he covered before
becoming national media coordinator for
oath keepers um
stewart was super enthusiastic about him
jason was at the time this thing that
stewart would do where he would have
a pedestal boy for a few months you'd
have a favorite person who could do no
wrong that was the newest brightest
shiniest person possible
and he
uh had oath keepers move jason to our
town here in eureka the
grocery store that he talks about where
he overheard oath keepers associated
people
uh talking holocaust denial that is the
grocery store in town that i go to every
week uh so we moved him up here oh
versus paying the rent on his cabin and
continued paying the rent on it like
paying rent thomas cabin for quite a
while i believe his moving fees were
covered stewart had hunted him
not only for a position in oath keepers
to be part of stewart's personal inner
circle
for
his tobacco valley eureka area community
that he wanted around him directly when
the apocalypse happened
wow and that's where i got to know jason
i i see and and of course stewart
continues his his relationship as uh uh
jason had kind of separate and stuart
had separated from the family and you
guys had kind of broke apart so tell me
what you
make of
what jason said do you think jason
included the entire story and do you
think he was a very he was a good
character witness uh for america to
understand who stewart is and who the
oath keepers are i think yes i think
because jason
is
a
pretty good example of somebody who
probably was like
as a as a libertarian was ready to be
swept up politically in oath keepers
got involved with it just to report on
it and ended up getting sucked in and
then was along for the ride for a good
while after that i think he is
positioned very well to tell people
about what oath keepers is and nothing
that he said today was wrong every
single thing was correct that oath
keepers is stewart they are a violent
militia
their vision for america is based on
using deceit to enforce their vision of
the deceit and violence to enforce their
vision of the future
everything is about stewart's ego
as a
paramilitary leader in his own mind with
the thinnest of fictions that he's not a
militia general and propping himself up
only thing he didn't do was in prior
interviews
had
left off with the time that he
officially resigned from oath keepers in
2014
when he did keep working for oath
keepers anonymously as a as a
contributing writer and an associate
editor
under a pen name through 2017
and had stewart living in his house
after he was no longer in our home
through to like late 2018 early 2019 and
continue to associate with him to the
extent
of testifying for stuart as a character
witness in our custody hearing
for the divorce case so he
i feel by a mission downplayed the
extent of his involvement with stewart
and how much longer that went on
after the holocaust denial conversation
that he talks about he might have been
trying to start the separation process
well before
but he was still pretty deeply embedded
for years to come
so he was he was
his relationship with stewart continued
enough that he was actually what's kind
of i guess ironic is he in open court
testified as a character witness in
support of characters of stewart's
character here um in open court or open
committee in front of america he
testified against
stewart's character so it seems like a
really a big 180 flip um within a few
years
of changing his mind about stuart which
that seems to be a pattern with stuart
so i guess it's probably not surprising
that even someone like jason
van tattenov who is part of the
libertarian movement as you said you
know the the ron paul rand paul
libertarian and we've talked about this
before how stuart that's kind of how he
got his start she wrote that wave
right right he can't and we talked about
it i think in the first interview where
we did the interview with you and your
mom we talked about that's how stuart
kind of started this whole oath keepers
and that's how he kind of started this
this idea of what it would become
and be so tell me about the dangers
because
jason um
laid out a very
very dark picture for america
of what it's like if we don't listen to
what these
right wingers are telling us that they
want and that they're going to do
i felt like he was kind of standing on
the table saying hey
listen to what the republicans the gop
and these right-wing militias and these
right-wingers and frankly some of these
neo-nazis are telling you that they want
to do these fascists are here
it's not a thing where you're where
they're almost here they are here they
are never right they're in government
they're a voting bloc their movement
they're trying to seize control of local
government positions they're on your
school board they're trying to shut down
your library
they are trying to form a flash mobs to
attack drag shows they're doing all of
the [ __ ]
and just like oath keepers the pattern
of behavior
that would lead to january 6 was long
established by those standoffs that went
largely unpunished and they largely
escaped consequences for
the the very standoffs that jase that
first the coverage of which first drew
jason in and that is what we have to
look at is every single thing
that goes unanswered that a right-wing
group does then becomes rehearsal so
what is happening right now attacks on
any event that they don't like uh
campaign ads
that
for congress critters that essentially
call for vigilante violence against
traders within the republican party
and
an increasing openness in rejecting
democracy and american ideals as a
failed experiment in favor of
uh more totalitarian christian
nationalism because that's what's just
what you got to do to get through the
hard times
well uh a dark picture that he painted
but one that i think america should pay
attention to especially with the
interviews that we've done with you and
some of the dark pictures you painted
of militia so there was another witness
there with him
um as kind of a a way to
i don't know maybe undermine this idea
that that you can you'll always be manga
if you're maga right because i i believe
that you have experienced that people
join the militia
they maybe believe in the quote-unquote
militia movement whatever that you know
shiny object may be at that exact time
but they discover what it's really about
and and defect
so what did you make of where jason
described his uh defectment but he also
the other witness heirs uh his defect
defecting from maga and the january 6
after he was an uh of violent
insurrections
so uh ayers is a classic example of
somebody
truly being swept up in the moment and
swept up in the movement where jason's
case was over the course of years
um ayers was swept up in a very short
time simply through being so thoroughly
plugged into the social media echo
chamber that was feeding on itself
and
it's i believe much sadder for his like
well for one thing ayers had the
presence of mind to wear a suit instead
of his uh
instead of his work jacket and band
shirt right right
um
but ayers is just
i i don't say simple on any derogatory
sense because he seems like somebody who
intentionally lives a simple life
because living an uncomplicated life and
focusing on the things that were
important to him is what he wanted i get
like everybody knows ayers you probably
everybody listening to this probably has
a couple of heirs in their
immediate circle of friends or
acquaintances or associates he's just
a regular run-of-the-mill joe
who was plugged into the energy of the
trump campaign and maga through social
media got super amped because he thought
he was being called to defend america
and was involved in a very serious crime
on behalf of puppet masters who
attempted to use him as a disposable
tool and he's only just realizing
that he's been used i found it very
interesting about ayers
that
he described how it destroyed
his life
um
have you seen that a lot in the militia
movement because manga isn't exactly a
militia movement the militia movement
may maybe maga but manga isn't a militia
movement maybe it's a white supremacist
movement maybe you could probably
describe it that way it's a broad
spectrum was like
like uh previously the committee had
been talking about uh
department of homeland security analysis
that they were seeing blended ideology
it's a broad spectrum
cultural conservative or at least
conservative coded blended ideology that
is designed to fit in everyone
that could potentially do violence or
simply mobilize as a voting bloc on
behalf of
conservative control of the country with
its figurehead as donald trump and
militia movements
like i talked about in my op-ed a little
bit ago
the militias generally
made a decision to align themselves with
maga because they saw it as a shake-up
of the status quo or
potential to
hold off the collapse and give them more
time or prevent it entirely or simply as
a business decision because aligning
with maga was the path of least
resistance for
continuing to stay relevant
after the trump's election and continue
to make money
so you mentioned your op-ed and raw
story which uh everyone should go take a
look at um and thank you for that piece
of work and i hope we we hear more from
you uh in written articles not just
video form but also written form i'm
going to do it shorter from here on out
okay well great well it is a very long
one but it's a great piece everyone
should go read it it's a raw story i'll
put the link here so everyone can find
it
yeah no no problem what i do want to ask
you though is pinning it all together
because i know that was something that
the committee was trying to do
so from the perspective of the committee
do you think they use jason and even
heirs in a way
that can kind of untangle some of this
web for some of these americans
that may believe some of this stuff may
believe the big lie or maybe not believe
it just it feels good to be on that side
do you think that the committee did a
good job at using their testimony to
tell part of that story or do you think
it could have been better worse what's
your opinion on the kind i think that
you did a pretty excellent job i think
ayers
um very clearly uh is a case study in
the average joe who was swept up in the
day of the insurrection the guys who
showed up for the million manga march
to support the president
and then were peeled off
into a riot targeted aimed at the
capital
it was a perfect representation
of the average joe who got sucked in
through his social media consumption
and was used as a patsy in a crime next
to him they have jason who is a very
good case study and characterization
of
somebody who was sucked into the militia
movement
and in and was there for the previous
standoffs who also
testifies very strongly about what the
militia always was
and
what these groups are like so that later
on when i believe the link is going to
be drawn
more firmly and in the work that the
community has already done between
showing
uh trump and his allies intentionally
inciting
the insurrection that on the side that
ayers was a part of the mob mobilization
of people that are used and also in
knowingly
um
utilizing and getting in bed with these
militias on the other side
like they knew that they demonstrate
once they demonstrate the links the
viewer will understand that the trump
white house and the republican party
knew exactly what they were doing with
that with this multi-pronged strategy
bring in bodies
use them to create chaos
have these militias who you understand
exactly what they are ready to execute a
mission under the cover of it now i do
understand that the committee speaking
of the committee they actually left out
some of
the uh script as it were or some of the
content that they wanted to show the
country
because they had the testimony of pat
sipoloni so i actually think there was
some content um and evidence that they
wanted to show the country they just did
not do that because of timing
um so maybe we'll get to see that in
later hearings maybe we won't i'm not
really sure
but i guess my question would be this
because not only did we
see the committee maybe
lack
the some of the evidence that they were
going to show but we also watched this
drama
of the founder of the oath keeper
stewart rhodes
in last week
go from
[ __ ] the committee to hey i want to come
testify again please let me testify
because he's kind of he's done a lot of
different positions here right when he
first was detained for the charges um
claiming full cooperation right and and
then he went and he actually did testify
in front of the committee so maybe
that's some of the the testimony that we
didn't get to see i i'm not really sure
i'm interested in seeing that one and
eventually it is used and i'm interested
in seeing why they've held it back for
this particular episode where they are
also utilizing an oath keeper's witness
right i i think that's interesting and i
don't know if it's because of the patsy
bologna testimony they felt it was more
relevant and important uh towards the
thrust of hey donald trump was behind
this all it wasn't exactly stewart
roadster rhodes was kind of a
you know a pawn in the in trump's game
right yeah he was a subordinate yes
right exactly because it seems to be and
we've talked about this before that
stewart rhodes was waiting on an order
from i don't know someone
you know from the white house that would
be able to declare martial law or the
interaction somebody who's a name
reminds you of rocks right that's
probably who it would be right well and
and that's the go-between is what you're
saying i believe that too because of uh
the the
the switch from the proud boys to the
oath keepers and then stewart having the
orders over the qrf the stash of weapons
we've talked about this before but the
most interesting thing that i found the
last week in the stuart road saga part
of this
is that
stewart not only wanted to now testify
but he had conditions kind of like steve
bannon right it almost felt like steve
bannon and stuart's little
saga here at that they wanted to go
before the committee this unselect
ridiculous you know unconstitutional
committee if they really believed all
that why would they now want to
participate but i found it funny that it
was almost a coordinated effort seemed
to be that they wanted to not only
testify under oath but they wanted it to
be live they wanted to be unedited they
could say anything they want now my
belief is that stewart was trying to
torch the criminal prosecution that the
doj has on him but give me your take
because it doesn't seem like the
committee is going to participate
in in a live
hot mic opportunity for stuart rhodes to
blast whatever he wants to blast or
steve bannon either one really um it
does two of the kind really well you
know one has an eye patch one has a scab
but
really they both have scabs well that's
true um
so but i guess i guess the point here is
that the committee has seemed to tell
them to basically [ __ ] off that you you
had your chance we we interviewed you we
have the evidence against you but what
is your take on stewart specifically of
why
he would want to now do this now that
the committee has come out with all this
evidence and basically it's damning
against
him and his allies
uh like roger stone steve bannon mike
flynn all the oath keepers the proud
boys
what do you think now stuart's decided
that he wants to go in front of a hot
mic in front of america to tell his
story is it because he wants to be
famous or does he actually want to tell
the truth
he absolutely doesn't want to just tell
the truth he wants to tell the story of
his ego now
possibly
i know that some people were probably
aware of tattenhofe testifying before it
went fully public
uh i think stewart is very much afraid
of tattenhof's testimony because
tatenhove
was with him through a lot of radical
[ __ ] and i think they also had a
probably very close personal
relationship because i'm just going to
this is basically public knowledge in
eureka
as it is now because i keep hearing
about it from people years after the
fact but uh tattenhofe and his wife were
very active in the swinger community
and i believe that is why one of the
reasons why stuart uh
wanted to move them up because there
have been multiple occasions where
there were couples that i'm pretty sure
were swinger couples that were also in
the prepper movement that stuart very
specifically wanted to live near us
or on the property in a kind of a
compound situation this is a pattern or
occurring pattern of behavior
and because stewart essentially wants to
be doc antle for anyone who's seen tiger
king
and but us a survivalist version where
also lords over all the husbands as
their military commander
uh
so
they're not just tiger wrangler but uh
uh warlord kind of thing yeah stewart
wants to be uh
uh the war or the warlord of a
post-apocalyptic polygamy
is essentially what it boils down to and
i think that element of it is probably
something like if jason didn't hasn't
talked about it already he might not
i know that
do you mean highly fair the jason in the
time since i'm about since i brought
this up in the time that he stewart was
living with him he had also broken his
leg
uh trying to cut fire is that why he has
the cane is that the reason why yes i
think that is a lingering effect from
that injury broke is like very badly he
had been working as a fireline emt for
large wildfire incidents so his main
non-oath keepers income stream is cut
off
he's injured his uh parenting his family
with his disabled wife who has chronic
health problems very vulnerable position
to be in while your uh boss is living
with you right so it's why i'm not as
angry with him as i would otherwise be
especially about the custody uh
testimony part the so but i think that
plays into how afraid stewart would be
of jason's testimony because there's
probably some non-oath keeper or militia
related things that strictly that jason
would be able to say that would crush
stewart's
um platform in the movement
more thoroughly than just him being a
radical because that's a good thing in
the eyes of his base
and
while he stewart is motivated by fear of
jason's testimony about his radical [ __ ]
and possibly their personal relationship
while he was living with them
stewart is going to take the opportunity
to grandstand because stewart is in all
or nothing at this point he believes
either he's going to die in prison or in
my opinion
really believes that at the 11th hour
trump is going to return to power or
future president desantis will pardon
him or he's just going to get acquitted
and beat the rap because he's that good
and his attempt to appear before the
committee
live unedited ron wriggling in the same
building as the committee
was an attempt to
rant at them attack their legitimacy
grandstand before america and attempt to
build a platform for when he gets out
and resumes being the general of oath
keepers
right so it sounds like some of the
stuff that we've talked before where
with the bundy ranch thing um stewart
really believes he may break the wrap
and i believe there's evidence in that
where he would did a jailhouse interview
with dinesh d'souza of all craziness um
you know stuart rhodes doing an
interview with dinesh d'souza doesn't
really give the select committee any
reason to take stuart road seriously at
this point no matter what he would say
the conditions are and whether he would
be under oath or not i think that's the
case there
and you you know better than most of how
seriously you can take stuart um do you
do you think do you think there is any
chance that hell freezes over or that
steward actually sits in front of a live
microphone with the select committee
what do you think
i think it's extremely unlikely because
his main reason for testifying would be
to make the committee into a circus with
himself as the main clown that's it
that's the that's the be all end-all of
any testimony that he would give to the
committee live and i think they know
that and know that it's not going to be
valuable and will only be used as clips
on as a clip show for steven crowder and
dinesh d'souza and all the other bottom
feeders to further galvanize his base
right so it's a it's more of a press a
press run for stuart in the future to
come
when when manga king trump becomes king
and pardons him he wants to establish
his big hollywood moment of speaking his
truth to all those corrupt politicians
sitting up there above them and rail
against them on behalf of the real
american people and he's effectively its
resume building well you know for the
future if stewart ever sees the light of
day um again maybe he can start a truth
social account and be over there where
all the truthful stuff it really is you
know if truth social
truth social is no matter how short
stewart's stint in prison is
um it will most likely outlive truth
social
well i i appreciate i always appreciate
your your commentary here but also your
insight
deep inside not just the militia
movement but uh stuart rhodes is mine i
know um you didn't choose to be
um tied to stuart like this you just are
there's just the nature of it so i just
i didn't uh i didn't choose this life
that shows me that's right that's right
and we appreciate you coming here and uh
speaking out and and your op-eds so tell
us a little more about the op-ed before
you go where people can find it what
it's about and what to what to expect
more of from dakota von adams
um tell them what to expect here if we
can find more work from you tell us
about that op-ed
all right so it's a piece i've been
putting off writing for a long time
mostly out of imposter syndrome and the
belief that i'm probably just not a very
good writer and but it's one that i have
needed to write and i was contacted by
raw story and
went you know
i'm gonna have to do that so it is
effectively the story of
the initial militia movement and patriot
movement programming that i received
through my childhood
and through my adolescence and teen
years with oath keepers
and then the series of shocks to my
belief system
that started to undermine
my mental conditioning
until eventually i realized that
everything was fake and i
what it effectively is is my best
attempt at showing you what the inside
of someone's head is like while they're
fully wrapped up in something like maga
or the patriot movement or a militia
cause
because i was
and what the inside of their head looks
like
when they begin to doubt and what it
takes for them to begin to doubt
and done my
absolute best to
take you on a guided tour through my
deprogramming journey in a way that is
hopefully valuable to people that have
lost friends and families and associates
and neighbors
to
right wing
cult gravity
well we appreciate your work in that uh
in that area and i think you if you just
probably google raw story dakota adams
or dakota von adams you will
it's got my previous name in the title
and any previous any future things that
i write
i'm going to include uh dakota roads or
dakota stewart road somewhere very large
and keyword searchable so that it's
brought up and in the future i'm working
on two pieces right now
one i've already told you the bullet
points of my experience at the gun show
that had a dividing wall down the middle
of the convention center with an anime
convention and my realization that the
militia crowd are
just the least fun
basket of weird nerds out of many weird
nerd fandoms
and then a longer and more serious piece
not as long as this op-ed which is an
excessive but uh longer more serious
piece about specifically my brush with
uh stormfront and other white
supremacist groups attempting to recruit
on 4chan and how ironically all of my
conditioning to see sinister
conspiracies in every shadow in my
childhood allowed me to clock the right
wing pipeline for what it was instantly
well i appreciate you coming on and
everyone go go follow uh dakota on on
twitter at dakota v adams i got that
right right it's at the bottom of the
screen there go follow dakota on twitter
he'll be posting those stories he'll be
yeah there you go there you go great
advertising great averages eventually
inaugurating a sub stack like all the
other crazy people great great that hey
i i love to hear that you're going to
start a sub stack and we can maybe on a
weekly basis hear what you have to say
and i'll tell you
please come
everyone can go to our youtube channel
and um see a playlist of the times that
dakota has come on and talked about the
oath keepers uh and the proud boys even
um but keep coming on if we see some of
this video from stuart out of this
select hearing i'd love to hear you uh
what you have to say so come back dakota
my friend uh have a good day i
appreciate you coming back on uh thank
you for continuing to inflict yourself
upon me and your viewers oh well the
viewers love you the audience loves you
they think you're brilliant so thank you
thank you dakota we'll talk to you soon
my friend
take care
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
i'm not really sure what happened there
yeah
we're supposed to come back from a
commercial break
uh and we're supposed to go to bone end
of the week
but you know
it happens it happens i had to edit
this and gabe's giving me a thumbs down
he's saying god you know
you go to the dentist and you come back
and this is the quality i come to this
it happens it happens all right let's
let's go to a quick break let's go to a
quick what do you think of the interview
before i thought it was good yeah i'm
very i'm very curious about this whole
uh tattoo
yeah
i mean it would be great if that became
out there's like oh yeah he hung out my
couch you know because he was
you know into that kind of stuff and
everyone and benny thompson's like i'm
sorry what was that wha
what was that well here's the thing
here's the thing
is i really held back the question that
i wanted to ask the question that i
wanted to ask in the moment to dakota is
dakota do you think if the select
committee would have asked the question
have you mr tatinov and stuart rhodes
ever had your balls touching that's the
question i think maybe yeah no i
think totally a professional legitimate
question that i totally would have had a
panel would have asked they're like look
when you who do you think would have
asked that do you think would have been
raskin do you think would have been
cheney who would have asked that
question
uh you know it's it's
maybe i don't know some it could have
been
maybe maybe cheney you know maybe she
was like [ __ ] whatever
right oh yeah absolutely like she's like
i could fundraise off these balls oh
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah these balls rubbing
together are gonna make me some change
baby some change you hear that jingling
you hear that jingling
i don't know so that's so that's the
question that's the question i really
wanted to ask but i i
i didn't have the i didn't have the nuts
to do it i guess i don't know i don't
know everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after these messages
right after these messages
with bonehead of the week
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100 made in the
usa don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
99.99 actual partying is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
didn't have the balls to
oh man
now it goes i guess
and that is how it goes yes but you know
the thing is here on bone end of the
week this week we have someone who has
asked who did have the balls to ask jim
jordan
[Music]
why he deleted a tweet
we do have that i think we're going to
play that video
during bone end of the week so let's get
started with bonehead of the week gabe
end of the week one of my favorite parts
of the entire week and be and it's
because the audience gets to decide who
is the bone hint of the week
they get to decide they get to decide so
let's go
to bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week
where you decide who is the bonehead of
the week and we break it down every
single friday in the second hour of the
tony michaels podcast
on youtube twitter twitch live every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
bonehead of the week this is this this
has got to be one of my favorite
segments
it's been a long it's been a long i mean
we've been doing it for a long time you
actually you text me last night you said
hey the the voting organic growth of the
voting is going up you people love every
week
this week was like i don't know 1300
votes and that's just on twitter last
week was like
around 800 votes so it's like
and that's great
we were we were late yesterday putting
it out and people were flocking to it
wait what about pull out huh did you say
pull out pull no no no no no no no i'm
not talking about tattoo and yeah
oh my god i got it
yeah
there's probably some other people on
bonehead of the week
that could have
you know should have pulled out
oh
maybe maybe a dishonorable mention or
something yeah maybe his last name
wouldn't be musk would it hmm
it smells a little musky does it smell
musky in here it might i don't know i
don't know so we did we did have three
um really boneheaded [ __ ] the
craziest part about when we put these
when we put this bowl out i noticed i
was like oh god these are all [ __ ]
elected members of of our government
what the actual [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
now obviously and we've gone through
some of this before but these
[ __ ] could be on this list
again we have to say this every goddamn
week these people could be on the list
every week
and we had a ton of comments where's the
all of the above where's the all the the
above right because here's the thing all
three of these [ __ ] came out of
the same [ __ ]
they all came out of the same you mean
like the same pile of [ __ ] or yeah yeah
they all kind of like brewed out and
you know uh but no it's it you know it
had to do with comments that were made
during a hearing
that they sat on for different things
two of them i believe on the same kind
of on the same committee panel
but they're all related to
the same sort of thing yeah yeah well
you know
we we missed the holly video the other
day because we went through the vivaldi
um the rob elementary footage from the
hallways of the of the evaldi um
elementary school there
so we missed the holi video so we played
it yesterday where he's just getting
absolutely [ __ ] torched
and i felt like that was the biggest
boneheaded movement our move that was
made so i actually i did i did vote i
did vote for josh hawley
okay i went with the jim jordan route
you know a lot of people went with jim
jordan but you know really honestly for
jim jordan to look the other way
of a sexual assault yeah it's
bone-headed but it's not surprising
right was really surprised that josh
hawley walked into
you know he really he really
he
he's a bonehead because he thought that
this woman was stupid you know he
automatically thinks that women are dumb
right exactly and that was that was i
think his bone dumb bone-headed mood
it's not surprising that jim he walked
into it and then he just kind of stomped
around in it
and was like what what is this
is this [ __ ] i'm in right right well he
is
he is a pile of [ __ ] for sure
and and and we played that video
yesterday of of josh holly being a
bonehead now why is what's the reason
why matt gatz is on this list is there
something oh yeah yeah yeah
well he tried to oh my god in some
ass backwards way
tried to seem like the good guy
in and
matt gatz tried to seem like the good
yeah he tried to because what he says
there's a clip um
i can send you the link but basically in
this hearing he tries to he tries to say
how
he was the good guy that voted for a
bill in florida that was around the
lgbtq community and protecting them and
then he tried to stay in the same kind
of breath throw that community under the
bus
and say that abortions
would uh
well i mean
basically tried to talk about uh lesbian
and bisexual relationships one not
really understanding what they were and
two tried to use again yeah he his place
is attempting to argue that lesbian rape
victi survivors should uh keep unwanted
pregnancy so safe sex couples can adopt
them because you try to say same-sex
couples adopt at a higher rate than
heterosexual couples and he's saying
that if they what don't have babies then
it's less opportunity for same-sex
couples to adopt it's
it's [ __ ] bananas to what for four
minutes you watch him really try to make
this case and seem like he's a total
protector of the lgbtq community
and it doesn't go the way that he wants
because he keeps digging and it it just
like holly he is [ __ ] stepping in the
[ __ ] and smearing it it's all [ __ ]
through the treadmarks of the shoes and
he's not getting it out have you ever
watched a kid when he steps in a big
pile of dog [ __ ] on the curb trying to
scrape trying to scrape the dog [ __ ]
yeah off the bottom of his shoe and it
just gets worse like he gets it up on
his [ __ ] leg and he's and then he's
gotta stop how much [ __ ]
how big is this [ __ ]
and then he's got a stick he's sitting
on the curb trying to pick the [ __ ] out
of his just out of his shoe are you are
you trying to admit that
is this something that happened to you
recently no no i've watched i've watched
a kid do this your kid not my kid no my
kid's not this [ __ ] dude
i'm talking about matt gatz as he was a
kid and i when i was a kid you know
there were some dumb [ __ ] around you
know they're mad gets types you know
types
the privileged kids who [ __ ] up and then
their dad saves them when they get a dui
but you know know you got a stick and
you're trying to pick the dog [ __ ] out
of it
yeah the creases of your shoes and then
you might flick up like a dog [ __ ]
booger up on your face or something
thank god yeah i know that that's matt
gatz probably in this clip that's all i
wanted to start my friday uh well you
can never be disappointed with me here
that's fine on the bone head of the week
so let's let's play the clip of matt
gets uh trying to get the dog [ __ ] out
of his shoes mr warbler what's the most
likely circumstance when a same-sex
couple would benefit from abortion
access
unfortunately we have women
who experience sexual assault
in fact uh lesbian and bisexual women
are more likely to experience sexual
assault than heterosexual women um that
their pregnancies are often involuntary
um and so these are individuals who
would need access to abortion care and
we'll shelve the bisexual woman for a
moment since my question's about the
same-sex couples and what's more likely
he's like i'm gonna talk about i'm gonna
talk about bisexual women here in a
minute
if you watch his body language right now
he seems
kind of nervous like he's like playing
with his hands and he's like
is kind of not as
smooth in his in his speaking here
probably because he doesn't know what
the [ __ ] he's talking about but also
because he's trying to you'll see in a
second really tries to make himself out
to be the good guy here and he's the
saving paid like the the [ __ ] patriot
saint of of the lgbtq community and
saying how he's helped he's trying to
help same-sex couples
by not allowing abortions so in the dog
[ __ ] stepping in scenario this is the
moment when the kid
realizes
yeah he stepped in the big pile of dogs
yeah yeah that's the moment that we're
oh oh god damn it
damn it
i mean you've you've stepped in a big
pile of dog [ __ ] before right yeah you
know the feeling that cut that you know
you know the you know the feeling that
comes over you when you step in that
baby
that's where
you don't even have to see it if you've
stepped in before you know
how it's the sliding it's the sliding of
the foot it's the sliding of the butt
and that's exactly where matt gats is
right now is feeling he's like because
that's why he had to shelf the bicycle
things like that he hasn't quite looked
down yet he's right stepped in and he's
like please don't have that [ __ ] please
don't let that be [ __ ] [ __ ] it [ __ ]
this is where it goes let's let's watch
a lesbian woman
having an unwanted pregnancy as the
consequence of a sexual assault
or a gay couple adopting in america
these are both laudable goals no i
didn't ask i know they are
which is more likely
i think that's uh impossible to know
whether or not we have tens of thousands
of same-sex couples that are look at the
guy behind him the guy behind him is
like you are a dumb [ __ ] and
that's that's someone who's on his side
there yeah right he's like god i told
you not to ask this question jesus
[ __ ] are you talking about here this is
ridiculous jesus are
raising families and uh raising children
as a consequence of adoption tens of
thousands we know that uh as a
consequence of census data so is there
any data you're able to reference that
it would be more likely for a lesbian
woman to have an unwanted pregnancy as a
consequence of rape than the formation
of a family through a same-sex couple
adopting it may not be more likely but
it's an important important interest is
it less likely
i'm not asking about the importance of
the interest i'm very limited on time
the question is thank god you're limited
on time thank [ __ ] god your limit on
time because your stupidity is just
astounding absolutely [ __ ] astounding
not only not only should matt gats not
be talking about anything to do with the
woman's body because he clearly does not
understand he should definitely
definitely not be talking about family
issues or
not be surmising on [ __ ] people
raping people
this is a [ __ ] that is is being
investigated
for sexual assault of a minor
okay sex trafficking a minor what in the
actual [ __ ] is happening here jesus
[ __ ] christ
i mean this dog [ __ ] just gets smellier
and stinkier and it's now coming up on
the sides of the shoes
it's about to get into the fabric and
once it goes in the fabric you ain't
getting that [ __ ] out nope that shit's
not coming out it's certain you would
concede that it's certainly more that
it's more likely in america that you
have same-sex couples adopting than you
do
lesbians having unwanted pregnancies as
a consequence of sexual assault right
well there may be also been a
misunderstanding about how uh same-sex
couples form families i also think it's
important to note that many bisexual
women are in fact in relationships with
other women yeah i i i
if a woman is with men and women they're
bisexual right
that is not true sir um an individual
who
he's like wait a second wait a second i
met me one of them one of them what she
calls them what she calls them their
lady one invite i met one in bisexuals
before like what the [ __ ] is this guy
talking about it's well he's like okay
are you getting confused with
a like non like monogamous relationship
like at the same time would imply that
one either you're you know involved in a
threesome right or two you're you're in
a non monogamous relationship right
you're dating multiple partners that
could be male and female right but he's
trying to be like
you're with both male and female that's
what no right that's not necessarily
true just because you have an attraction
to both sexes doesn't mean you're you're
you said you're only bisexual when
you're dating both of them and that's it
and it's right he's such a [ __ ]
bonehead see that's that's the problem
is these [ __ ] idiots are so goddamned
stupid they have smoked and done and
drank all their [ __ ] brain cells away
that they can't imagine they can't
imagine any kind of sexuality other than
their [ __ ] own and i understand that
maybe matt gantz does understand a
bisexual
sexuality but he clearly he clearly does
not have the brain power to really
compute it outside his own [ __ ] head
like he just does not have the brain
power to understand that other people
are gonna have different [ __ ]
belief systems they're gonna have
different world views they're gonna have
different sexualities matt it happens
man it happens stay the [ __ ] out of
their business would you please also
just because a woman doesn't wanna date
you or be around you doesn't make her a
lesbian just makes that she has
standards and doesn't want to be
involved with anyone like he thinks
every woman has a lesson you think
that's why i think
he's like they don't like to talk to me
they're all lesbians exactly he'll be
like oh that [ __ ] she's a lesbian
guarantee every woman said that she has
said
physically assault and she wasn't having
it and stood up for herself maybe
[ __ ] smacked him or said nope not
into it he was like go back to his
friends and go she's a [ __ ] lesbian
dudes she she wasn't having it it's like
why wouldn't any why wouldn't any woman
want to have this gauge and it's like
the fact that you had to ask that
question all right here we go i was
retracted to people of both sexes both
men and women male and female someone
who's bisexual they can be in long-term
monogamous relationships i don't ask
this to be dismissive but so you're
saying lesbian women are also capable of
being into men
that is not what i said i said bisexual
yeah but my question is about lesbians
same-sex couples right because i i care
about this issue deeply with the support
of the human rights campaign i sponsored
the legislation to get rid of the
statutory prohibition on gay adoption in
florida i felt that was very bigoted and
i believe families are defined by love
more than blood and i was worried that
if the lgbtq community and if the
advocacy organizations for same-sex
couples somehow reorient to be
maybe maybe he's trying to get answers
here he's not actually asking for
america maybe he's asking for himself i
i have an adopted son who's not blood
but it's love you know and it's like are
you are you trying to tell us something
about nestor right now he's trying to
really figure out bisexuality he's like
i got rid of this law but nestor's not
by blood but i see him more than blood
what is by defined bisexual again for me
again please tell me exactly
what it would be let's just give the
scenario if i was a bisexual i mean
meanwhile the guy behind him is like oh
[ __ ] look at this guy he's like jesus
christ he's like is his time up is his
jesus christ pro-abortion enterprise
that that could actually result in fewer
same-sex couples having access to the
family formation
that gives them okay i can't i can't i
can't anymore because the prohibition of
abortion
actually makes it to where some same-sex
couples won't be able to do procedures
to give them their own blood family you
[ __ ] boneheads but also the fact that
he's trying to say that if we if we
allow a doc if we like abortions it'll
bring down the number of adoptions
within same-sex couples okay first off
there are plenty of kids who are in the
unfortunate situation that are in an
orphanage or they're you know their
wards of the state or or whatever it
might be that they have no you know they
don't no longer have a family right they
have been put up for adoption they live
a home like these are kids
there are a ton of children
again unfortunate situation that there
are a ton of children who do not have
homes you know what i think almost we
can almost take a screenshot of this and
and do the tweet we'll adopt your
children with these two
definitely definitely
but i look at i look at matt gates and
he's trying to make this weird [ __ ]
assumption that adoption that there's a
direct relationship with uh you know or
an indirect relationship to say like
increase in adoption decrease in or
increase abortion decrease in adoption
among same-sex couples like where the
[ __ ] do you get that logic like the
pretzel
twisted
gears turning and matt gates his head
he's like i'm making a good point here
and everyone else that's watching this
even the guy behind him is like
man i told you this was not what it's
not a good idea
he's like i he's like i gave you the
numbers and you kept telling your you
know confirmation by she's like yeah but
then there's less babies and less babies
i mean less adopted children and it's
like matt that's not at all what's going
on here he's such a [ __ ] bonehead
matt metz is such a [ __ ] bonehead and
i'm glad he made it on bone of the week
and i'm actually sad that i gave my vote
to josh hawley now now that i i watched
this clip i wish i could go back and
change my vote uh stop the steal stop
the steal
um please someone commit voter fraud and
change my vote dumbest dumbest [ __ ]
argument i've ever heard
it is kind of pathetic um we do i i want
to make time for the alpha cuck but we
do have a a new arrival here on bonehead
of the week and this honorable mention
because we've had a musk here before
several times but this is a new one yeah
this is a new musk this is
how do you say his name is it ariel
arrow arrow
carol musk who is this musk gabe who is
this
this is the father
of elon musk oh
this is the one who gave elon musk the
money you know because remember elon
musk is not self-made he got money from
his family so so what does his father do
is he's in charge of some kind of like
minds or something where yeah
[Music]
you know south africa i think he's an
engineer
uh if i remember the title crackle but
yeah he made his money in the minds of
south africa where
the origin of the money that elon musk
got to kind of start his
his entrepreneurship venture
um
yeah surely this guy is not is not in
the news here and on bonehead because
he's a scuzz bag i'm sure that's not no
not at all not at all it can't be i mean
this is what happened
let's start with the woody woody allen
was like hey guys
i'm into dating my daughter and then
errol musk said
uh hold my beer
and then entered the chat
and because this [ __ ] is crazy and the
the reasoning
for why he did what he did
is and you see it on the screen here i'm
sure
i'm sure his reasoning makes all the
sense when you read the headline here
elon musk father
errol musk announces he has welcomed a
second child not a not a child a second
child with his step-daughter yeah who
has raised who he has raised since she
was four years old this is really
[ __ ] gross the only thing we are on
earth is for
for is to reproduce
oh my [ __ ] god so wait a second so is
he still married to her mother is it
is it is that what it is i believe so
so i don't know any i don't know any
different i mean who knows these guys
maybe magnets should come ask questions
about how you know it's like right
so how does this work how does this work
if i wanna matt getz could be like wait
a second so i have a
adopted son yeah if i got a a
stepdaughter an adopted son do i get to
you know what's the what's how how does
that work and you probably start asking
that [ __ ] in committee you know just to
figure this out i mean you might as well
put in the [ __ ] this is the second child
the second
now elon musk has said the same stupid
thing of course we've seen the elon [ __ ]
where he's got kids he he knew about and
or he had twins last week or i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on with this
i mean the guy's got elon's got 10 kids
right that we know of
i wonder where he gets it from i wonder
where he gets it from yeah yeah yeah
it's one of those things where it's uh
i mean it's [ __ ] gross but like
spread it you gotta spread the seed you
know
you gotta you gotta fertilize the speed
and
that is earth right
there is um
uh i'm blanking on it right now hold on
one sec well the rotten apple does not
fall far from the tree here oh not at
all that's for sure for certain the
rotten apple does not fall far
from the nasty old tree because we i
mean elon's been in the news again he's
been he's had a rift with trump um
recently over him walking away and
pulling out of twitter the one time he
did pull out well he's pulled out a lot
he just
doesn't like to um pull out on other
things he likes to trade horsies away
for it um
and apparently arrow musk now too jesus
[ __ ] christ
um
oh god i really i'm gonna take a drink
of water i got a nasty taste in my mouth
no it's fine i mean you know
i i had some mouthwash earlier
the uh
these two are [ __ ] gross
the
well also there's if anyone has watched
the netflix documentary our father which
i definitely recommend
there's a cult yeah
there's a cult that he's in which is the
quiver full right and it's that same
this is these
wait wait arrow musk is in that cult no
no no i don't know if he's in i don't
know i don't know what i'm saying is
in that documentary which i definitely
recommend to anyone this is not
sponsored uh anyone who wants to know we
don't get money from them yeah yeah yet
but yet yeah yes
in that documentary they talk about a
cult that um the doctor's involved with
is called quiverful right and it's a
christian cult that is the ideology is
to be fruitful and multiply and you know
blah blah as many kids as possible
that's the same type of thinking the
same type of ideology or or thinking
that um
that elon and errol musk have right they
want as many kids they want to spread
the bounty of earth you know they want
to spread their seed they want to
multiply like that's that [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
you know and i don't know if it's
because they actually believe in it who
knows
but
they definitely have the same line of
thinking to have as many kids as
possible you know
well elon again has been in the news
he's gonna get sued by twitter oh yeah
and you know when we we went through
that but i want to go to before we get
to the winner
um because i definitely want to spend
some time on on the winner because
it is very gross
what the winner did this week but really
honestly the entire right-wing apparatus
followed him
in in this pursuit yeah
they followed him into the dark trying
to prove something that was
very easily
uh
proven as fact they called it a lie and
they've shamed a little girl um so we're
going to get to that but i want to go to
this alpha cuck
looks like we're getting back to mr
stein here i had to i had to so why why
did you
of course we watched the video earlier
right on the show
of him and merge mercury her foot green
emerge
talking about you know downplaying the
fact that he was sexually harassing
uh aoc on the capitol steps and it
wasn't funny it was sexual harassment is
what it was
um you know jokes are funny and sexual
harassment is not funny right so so it
wasn't funny alex but why why do you
have him here on the uh dishonorable
all right
yeah yeah yeah okay so the the main
reason is uh
for his you know misogyny right his
attack on aoc okay the defense that he
has to say it's just a joke right right
i really like her all this stuff but
here's the thing
alex stein
is you know has attacked other people
whether it be ted cruz or it be
uh
eye patch mccain i'm patrick kane right
dan crenshaw which i've attacked him i i
have said yeah i have said dan crenshaw
needs to get a [ __ ] glass eye and
wear it yeah
you know just like last action hero put
the glass eye in boom done you could do
cool stuff right
so alex stein i just you know the
the commitment to double down right so
he goes on it wasn't until i watched a
clip of marjorie taylor green when i was
like nah [ __ ] this guy he's going on
alpha [ __ ]
now the history of of uh of alex stein
is that this is anyone who doesn't know
this nobody right
he's got a show uh that is about um it's
called conspiracy castle right and i'm
going to play a clip from a
what he considers to be stand up
and there's actually uh oh so this is
where the comedian part comes in where
he's right so he you may have seen him
on tucker carlson or he does a bit or
multiple bits when he goes to like town
hall committee
you know kind of meetings right there
are people that troll committee means
really well there are the two guys from
san diego area oh you know this is this
a guy that was down in texas that went
and he
there's a video of him he made the rap
yeah there's the rap one he did the one
where he showed up with the mask he
didn't really cover 19.
yeah yeah so there are people that show
up to these meetings that are either
completely serious right
which you're like [ __ ] this guy is crazy
or they're people that go into meetings
and they try to they try to troll and
they try to make a joke of it right the
people that i've seen do it really well
there are two two friends think it's san
diego they try to get the paul walker
statue made like viral videos where they
go in and there's like a couple surfer
bros and we're just like talking to the
committee here and we want to get paul
walker's statue you know stuff like that
which is like you know it's trivial but
it's funny right
not not attacking a group it's just like
good fun
now you've got people like alex stein
who show up and do crazy [ __ ] they're
mocking science making fun of people who
had coveted uh they're making fun of
women they're misogynist doing attacks
here and there but it's all under the
name of
comedy right funny
it's on it you just don't get it you
don't get the sarcasm it's like well
what what purpose is my bigotry you know
you just don't get it
so anyway that's the thing that alex
stein does now what people might not
know
is he's actually a reality tv star oh
whoa
so surprised me when saying that this
[ __ ] box right so he was on a reality tv
show called abc's the glass house
uh he only lasted two episodes then he
was on cnn he voted off
uh i believe so it's just i can't
imagine you can't i can't imagine yeah
yeah i'm really wise
and so then he was on cmt's sweet home
alabama and worst cooks in america and
the food networks
on the food network in 2013 which i
wasn't able to find a club so is he like
a career reality tv star or something i
think so that's where he's getting and
that's around here you know yeah i know
so most people know him for his you know
uh his dumb takes
on in these in these meetings and stuff
or on tucker carlson right as the white
power hour as he said
but he's also been on another show which
is a bravo series called online dating
rituals of the american mail
oh right and it was a document series
sounds like ball tanning uh
if you look at the guys that were on the
show it's a bunch of basically
uh preppy white dudes kind of you know
they could all be the alpha cup yeah
yeah
so that one is a docu-series that was
supposed to unmask the world of the
booming this is in
2014 or something i think or 10 15.
the booming online dating culture from
the male perspective because who who
doesn't want to learn more about what
it's like for a white male or a bunch of
way right
white dudes yeah yeah he's like i tried
to talk to this girl at the bar and then
she told me to [ __ ] off and then i was
like she's a lesbian
so now i've heard that before yeah crazy
yeah i know they're all the same they're
like she didn't like me she's a lesbian
so all these guys these white guys who
are triggered or you know whatever can't
get their date because you know being
themselves is not actually
attractive uh it follows these men as
they hunt
for their ideal partner or hook up
whatever it might be
so you get an inside perspective of the
male psyche from the beginning stages of
trolling
and communicating online to landing a
date with a potential match
this guy is a piece of [ __ ] all right i
watch clips of the show
uh where he is the villain like and they
knew when they casted this show they
knew exactly who they were getting okay
so they they found this guy's an [ __ ]
right he's gonna be the villain of the
show you know and he plays that role
really well right he i mean he's not a
great villain but he's just an [ __ ]
on the show where he's like talking
about girls wade and da da like
that's the role that he's playing now
it's a question of like are are we
acting in this role like are we are we
kind of ratcheting this role up or are
you playing true to the persona that you
are
and i believe based on clips that i've
seen and different things like alex
stein99
isn't a character
alexstein99
is actually alex stein oh so
there's a clipping piece of [ __ ] oh dude
bonafide [ __ ]
bonafide piece of [ __ ] so i hope that
you know we tag alex stein he can come
here and watch the show you know yeah
people can i i hope you know
yeah i hope so too so there's a clip
[ __ ] them
where he goes and does what he calls
stand up now whether he means it in an
ironic fashion he's like oh it's not
really stand up it's just me i mean he's
standing up he's standing he's standing
up it's in a south dallas club he's a
white guy in preppy clothing like that's
his his shtick right that's alex stein99
but in this clip he talks of a lot of
various [ __ ] right he talks about uh
harris as
uh as potential president but this how
long do we have to watch this douchebag
this clip i believe is uh
one no it's 34 seconds i only clipped
out one section which is he talks about
the private prison industry you might
have to upload it did you upload it i
put it on the show i mean i can upload
it sure yeah you might you might want to
upload it so it's
decent because when we play it across
the internet it has right right right
right so so basically
um
in this in this stand-up routine
whatever you want to call it but he
calls it stand up he goes in there and
he's talking about the private prison
industry and he talks about music and
how it's like this this uh
this kind of beast that eats itself the
prison industry
uh the music industry tells the you know
to commit these crimes and go into
prison in the prison industry says to be
successful you got to make music and
it's a cycle right but in there
he spreads uh
misinformation or disinformation because
i know he is 100 because he brings up a
name
and he says this person
from the black community oh
owns a stake in private prison industry
turns out
that's not true
so he's just making [ __ ] up he's just
because it's funny gabe it's funny right
it's just i go ahead and play the yeah
just play it okay let's play it doesn't
stop there listen this is why i want to
help all my black brothers and sisters
and then in the 80s they got all the top
record executives and this is what they
said they said oh we gotta have black
music that influences violence and drug
use why because we invested in all the
private prisons so what we're gonna do
is all the record labels own all the
private prisons so you're going to
influence black people to go to jail to
fill up their private prisons and you're
like alex what the hell that can't be
true look it up one of the biggest guys
that owns private prisons michael jordan
has one of the biggest investors in
private prison so
okay so let me just tell you right here
none of that was jokes none of it yeah
no none of that none of that none of
that clip jokes jokes all of it all of
it was in a room uh looking at at black
people
being racist
in front of black death it's not and it
looked like they had their cameras that
like
we got to film this but yeah yeah it
don't cause they almost felt like these
this white dude's got some balls he
saved
the whole set that i have here is seven
minutes i was like [ __ ] it this is the
only part that i want to show but he
talks about a ton of random [ __ ] in here
and and talking you know about
everything from prisons to music what's
the music in the background what is no i
whenever they edit did he edit it like
that i think i think so yeah yeah
the title is alex alex
stein keeps it real in the hood alex
alex listen if you aren't listening out
there number one
i i'm not the best video editor
between the two guys on the screen but i
do know this you should really keep your
background music down so you can hear
like the actual maybe he realized the
jokes the jokes weren't
so here's the thing he claims he goes oh
yeah because you know he's trying to
make a point here right he's trying to
say how
how products right you know people
within the black community are are
products of the prison industry and
those who are successful whether it be
through sports or or music or whatever
try to get
other people in the black community back
through the prison system right because
he says it's like a revenge kind of
thing like well i think it's like he's
trying to make some argument on how like
i don't know ownership or something you
know some dumb [ __ ] b is like not he's
like look white people aren't the bad
ones it's also black people because
black people own the prison industry
this [ __ ] because here's the thing
he's trying to infer and tell you like
oh yeah michael jordan how many michael
jordans do you know right you know two
right but but you probably only know one
that he's referring to which is michael
basketball jordan
here's the thing it's not that michael
jordan there is a michael jordan that
does own a stake in the private prison
industry but it is not michael jordan
the nba all-star from the bulls okay
that is not who he that is that is not
the person but of course
he goes there to make a point
and says oh [ __ ] there's a guy named
michael jordan this is totally going to
back up my brain right and so he does
that to be like oh yeah michael jordan
from the bulls that's who that's what
i'm talking about and said it's some
random michael jordan some rando some
random but this is the type of [ __ ] that
alex stein does right he's gonna he'll
he he goes just like his daddy his
[ __ ] daddy and the white power hour
tucker carlson his point is that he
wants to
make it he wants to make a claim
he will uh he will not have evidence to
back it up and if he does have something
that
somewhat sounds like it he will finesse
it to make his point right it's what ben
shapiro does
um
it's what charlie kirk does it's what uh
jordan uh peterson does like all of
these guys are the same type of people
they're ball tanners alpha cucks
want to get with women but get pissed
off when they don't like you and so then
they take it back out on a woman and say
it's a joke it's a joke
it's really it's really healthy
that's you know and again he's like well
you don't get i guarantee if he sees
this he'll be like well you don't get
the humor it's supposed to be like
ironic like it's anti-comedy right and
it's like but it's not if you're just
making [ __ ] up it's almost like someone
else we
ran into the last couple weeks who
doesn't also understand
satire and comedy either but you know
i guess we only have one alpha cuck per
week so we give it to alex stein let's
move on to the winner
of the bonehead of the week
jim jordan this was like it was a
blowout with this [ __ ] idiot yeah
um the real the reason why is because
jim jordan is almost as much as trump as
the king of maga jim jordan might be the
king of boneheads i don't know what do
you what do you think is that i mean
look the guy's been in how many years
how many years has he been in it's like
jim jordan
he's been in
a week was way too long
yeah yeah
let's see jim jordan years in congress
16 17 uh he has been in office since
2007 so 15 almost 16 years right
and still and still doesn't own a
[ __ ] jacket
doesn't own a jacket
has not passed a bill
the only thing he has to his name is
that he helped cover up the sexual
assault
um claims
and that were a part of the wrestling
team
when when he was at um
uh ohio state yeah ohio state
and
now
to his name he's adding the fact that
he's going to throw a 10 year old girl
under the bus and say that it's all made
up because here's the stolen
a 10 year old girl was raped in ohio
she got pregnant um
because republicans and fascists don't
want little little babies to have babies
in this country right um because they're
gonna force a gov big government
pregnancy on a ten-year-old girl
they don't want her to have an abortion
in ohio so she had to go to indiana now
there's some disgusting [ __ ] that
happened with the attorney general and
still continuing happening with attorney
general over in indiana because he's a
slime ball too just like jim jordan here
but jim jordan tweeted that it was fake
and the reason why they tweeted this
because joe biden
talked about the story in front of a
microphone so they just assumed anything
joe biden says is a [ __ ] lie and it
wasn't just him it was all of them every
[ __ ] last one of them said it was all
lie because they're like oh where's the
guy who raped her did you arrest him did
you arrest it and they arrested him and
then and then he deleted the [ __ ]
that said it and here is the clip
of jim jordan being asked about why he
[ __ ] deleted that tweet the amer
american people want to know you piece
of [ __ ] you're an elected official why
are you [ __ ] denigrating a little
child
who who you're you're you're advocating
for big government to force her to have
a baby you piece of [ __ ] let's see what
he says it's probably boneheaded i'm
sure you voted for him why'd you delete
the tweet
well because we learned that there's an
illegal alien did this heinous crime you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] so here he is he he
obviously has the chance here to own up
to why he deleted it
no he won't he won't i mean what would
be the excuse if it was not you know you
know legal alien right oh they are super
excited super excited about the person's
name i mean it's exactly like what
happened with uvalde they were like they
immediately went to oh he's hispanic oh
oh you know what he's definitely from
he's definitely a legal alien and you're
like nah he's from [ __ ] south dakota
okay right he's not the opposite side of
the [ __ ] border he's closer to canada
than mexico and also the assumption like
he's mexican he came over the border and
he went right in uvalde and he was like
i hate americans
that's the same type of [ __ ] right you
had people and then even after the fact
of that that situation where they all
jumped on the bad wagon to say he was
illegal
nobody
nobody said oh [ __ ] got it wrong gun or
i'm gonna delete this tweet
right right but your code the code for
vets or whatever the [ __ ] one was on
the the veteran
uh twitter account doubled down
and didn't even delete the tweet right
and they were like oh you know it's
mental health right so they'll always
jump from the next thing and this is
where they're like here here it is no
good he's illegal
well and the reason why they're
terrified of this story because this
trashes the reason why they want roe v
wade and we watched a [ __ ] clip
also
where
someone tried to claim that a 10 year
old girl
having an abortion is not an abortion
because she's a 10 year old girl which
makes no sense whatsoever they're doing
everything they can about this story
yeah
the [ __ ] and not have the american
people vote against them in the midterm
which i believe is coming but let's
listen to what else this [ __ ]
bonehead has to say
um
did you apologize for the girl in the
family for suggesting that i never
doubted the child
oh
the [ __ ] out of here okay i've had
enough of this piece of [ __ ] i never
doubted the child you literally said it
was fake [ __ ] you said it was fake you
said it wasn't real and you're like oh
yeah here comes another one of these
fake stories coming out of joe biden in
the left-wing media and it's like
well i i wish i had time i'd show a clip
of uh
eric swalwell eric swallow did such a
good job of just
wadding jim jordan up and throwing him
in the [ __ ] trash about this story oh
yeah i wish i had actually you know what
let's
let's let's do it yesterday miss
warbelow speaking of disinformation jim
jordan
called a ten-year-old rape victim a liar
a ten-year-old rape victim was called a
liar by the ranking member of this
committee and i know that he did that
because he hates the president it's
clear every day from his statements and
the statements from mega republicans
that they don't like joe biden so
they're going to call him a liar that's
fine but what is worse
is the reason that he did it
is because he doesn't like
what that rape victim represents which
is that this
law
from the supreme court jobs and the laws
that will follow in states like ohio and
texas and georgia and other states
will bring us government mandated
pregnancies
for 10 year olds
fourth graders little girls
babies and to deflect from that
yeah they choose to bully and beat up
transgender individuals who represent
fewer than one percent of americans
and they try and deflect that because
they don't want anyone in america to
realize that they don't just want to
wage a war on women
they're now expanding it to a war on
little girls so miss warbelow let's go
back to where we started here
boom that is how you slam dunk that
[ __ ] in chat trash thank you
eric swalwell uh let's give jim jordan
his due for bonehead of the [ __ ] week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no contest jim jordan is the bonehead of
the week not even not even a [ __ ]
prayer
thought or prayer yeah that the other
boneheads had with jim jordan uh calling
a ten-year-old girl a liar when the big
when she wanted to force a big
government pregnancy on her and force
her to carry a baby to term [ __ ] that
guy [ __ ] all these boneheads really oh
yeah especially [ __ ] [ __ ] jim jordan
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him [ __ ] him make sure to
follow us at tony michael's pod go vote
every single week for bone end of the
week we will break it down in the second
hour
on the youtube channel don't forget to
subscribe there we broadcast live every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
from youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcast from the minus touch facebook
page also what we do with bone end of
the week gabe is we actually clip it out
and play it on sunday
just bonehead of the week on sundays and
yeah when it comes out on sunday
make sure to tag alex stein99 that's it
that's it share it around spread it
around all right spread it like herpes
which i'm sure he has all right i'm sure
i'm sure
it happens it happens it happens alex
i'm going to see the best of us
it happens well that has been bonehead
of the week thanks for joining us stick
around we have some announcements right
after this
[Music]
[Applause]
bonnet of the week bram
boom
boom
i did not know a lot of that about alex
stein i definitely knew jim jordan was
supposed to there is more there is more
that i could dig up on alex stein and
i've got i i did find some clips of him
uh doing his his reality tv show the one
i'm bravo i'm sure it's fantastic but
yeah like there is there i think the
video is called worst villain in in
reality tv history and i don't know if
they mean that like he tried to be a
villain and he did a really shitty job
of or he's just a [ __ ] he's just a
horrible
piece of [ __ ] and person probably just
did a good bad job at playing one as
well right right he he did a good a good
job of being himself but a bad job at
being the villain that everyone's like
oh he's probably not like that in real
life he is he absolutely is he is a
piece of [ __ ] and thank you for joining
us all this week monday through friday
every single weekday two hours
on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page the news i want to give
you out there is don't forget next week
thursday there is not an announced time
but there is a hearing right now
tentative on thursday we believe it'll
be about eight o'clock eastern so be
looking for our coverage to start about
seven eastern
in prime time on thursday as soon as we
can confirm that time we will try to get
a link out to everyone so make sure to
go follow us at tonymichaelspod at the
tony michaels and i am gabe sanchez also
go over to the midas touch youtube
channel subscribe there we will have our
coverage on the midas touch network
don't forget to subscribe here too when
you're on our youtube channel and
subscribe to the tony michaels podcast
you can also download every single
episode monday through friday on apple
spotify google or any of your favorite
directories also we have a best of a
best of on saturdays and the bonus of
the week that you can download so you
can download michael's podcast
seven days a week no shut the front door
tony seven days a week a
seven days of [ __ ] week right here on
the tony michael's podcast so everyone
have a safe and wonderful weekend
be safe out there we have uh kovitz
spreading around and also the monkey box
gabe sent me a video the other day so be
careful be safe anyone in l.a
it looks like we're going to have the
mask mandate uh
the numbers are going up again so i
think in the next on and by the end of
july it looks like the masked media will
be back in effect so so be safe be
vigilant about who and where you're
hanging out definitely don't hang out
with a bunch of right-wingers i'm sure
that's probably not a good idea not just
for the disease part but right no yeah
yeah i mean that's part i mean it's a
mental kind of you know disease that
they they spread poison
stay safe everyone great weekend
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born had asked me